d'abord rappelé qu'au mali
notre engagement est un engagement dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme
l'islamisme radical le djihadisme c'est
un combat qui est mené au nom des
valeurs est d'ailleurs à l'appel
historique du mali je me souviens très
bien de l'opération serval aujourd'hui
la réalité c'est qu'une femme face à une
junte militaire qui préfèrent les
miliciens d'un groupe privé wagner liés
à la russie et la situation sans doute
on ne peut pas rester dans un pays dans
les forces politiques jusqu'à l'arrivée
par la force et hors de tout contexte
démocratique ne veulent plus de la
présence de nos armées et d'un certain
nombre de nos alliés qui sont à nos
côtés
le président de la république chef des
armées en lien avec les partenaires
européens
doit faire le poids savoir dans quelles
conditions on peut continuer assuré
parce que se battre contre le terrorisme
l'islamisme radical c'est se battre bien
sûr dans ces pays mais c'est aussi se
battre souvenons nous des attentats que
nous avons connus pour des valeurs que
nous avons en partage notamment en
europe et
savoir comment nous allons réorganiser
cela cela dépend du président de la
république le parlement va être associés
à la réflexion la semaine prochaine
peut-être un peu embêté illusion avec
emmanuel macron vous allez rencontrer
jean castex à ce que bien sûr
exceptionnellement je pense qu'on ne
peut pas rester dans un pays qui ne
quittons les forces politiques même
arrivés par la force ne veut plus moi je
pense à nos soldats à puis j'ai quand
même une pensée
58,58 de nos soldats sont tombés nous
avons eu des centaines de blessés nous
nous sommes retrouvés dans la cour des
invalides ou ailleurs pour leur rendre
hommage on leur doit me semble-t-il au
delà de l'hommage
eu un peu une dette une dette
de deux patries et c'est ce que nous
allons je crois devoir partager au delà
des clivages politiques
[Musique]